[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du cetud plaisir comme chaque
jeudi l'essentiel des informations pour
passer un bon week-end dans les yvelines
et tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine expositions jeux et escape game
en ce début d'année 2020 les nouvelles
technologies investit 50 ans melvin et
dévoile quelques-uns de leurs secrets
ce week-end c'est la nuit de la lecture
en journée pour les heures en soirée
pour les autres nous ferons le point sur
les rendez-vous dans les yvelines et
l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme une exposition du bénévolat et
du cinéma
les nouvelles technologies sont partout
jusque dans les expositions trois
d'entre elles viennent tout juste de
débuter sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
les nouvelles technologies se mêlent
aloi à la roue des vals leurs secrets un
moyen d'initier les intéressés ou de
rassurer les inquiets un sujet fait avec
aurélie rose impossible de passer à côté
les nouvelles technologies s'expose à
saint quentin en yvelines au prisme un
couple d'artistes explore les capacités
de ces technologies pour créer il
scénographie de petit monde quatre
installations interactives comme cet
arbre réagissant au toucher tout parle
de notre relation au corps à
l'environnement et
comme dans la plupart de nos
installations faites nous explorons
beaucoup la question du toucher de la
relation à l'eau de la relation à
l'élément naturel de l'art aussi à la
commanderie réalité virtuelle côtoient
intelligence artificielle
océane omar de caspar ravel créer une
oeuvre on continue six oeuvres
s'interrogent sur l'impact du genre dans
la création et le ressenti du spectateur
c'est un petit clin d'oeil à l'écriture
inclusive parce que en fait ce projet
est un projet que nous avons accompagné
et mis en oeuvre un projet d'une
association des étudiantes qui s'appelle
est rien les gens se posent des
questions posent des questions et puis
discutent les nouvelles technologies
lève un peu de leur mystère dans un
cabinet de curiosités avec entrée dans
la matrice l'atelier des sciences invite
dans un parcours en plusieurs parties un
voyage dans le numérique et dans le
monde de l'informatique avec la
présentation notamment d'ordinateurs des
années 70 une vue sur le
le premier ordinateur et puis
l'évolution jusqu'à aujourd'hui
un parcours semé de manipulations
ludiques pour comprendre certaines
innovations et les nouvelles
technologies n'ont pas fini de nous
surprendre
et justement cette exposition peut se
terminer par une animation à réserver on
en parle est qu un autre invité antoine
vignolles bonjour bonjour vous êtes
chargé d'actions culturelles à l'atelier
des sciences donc depuis le 15 janvier
dans la chapelle une esprit prom a été
installé déjà pourquoi avoir choisi
cette animation pour finaliser
l'exposition 7c'est escape room est
intégré donc à l'exposition entrée dans
la matrice qui est présenté à la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
par l'atelier des sciences tout le
parcours de cette exposition comme vous
l'aviez dit justement passe par trois
pôles traitant du numérique de
l'informatique et 7,7 skis et promet
effectivement dialogue également avec
ces différentes thématiques que ce soit
avec la programmation l'effectuer use
les nouvelles technologies alors elle a
été conçue par la rotonde le centre de
culture scientifique de l'école des
mines de saint-etienne et artem cab sont
des créateurs associés
elle s'appelle liotta et son but c'est
d'identifier des sources de piratage
internet exactement le contexte de cet
ex de c'était escape room et que depuis
plusieurs semaines sur internet
d'étranges phénomènes apparaissent
toutes les vidéos de chats ont disparu
d'internet plus de vidéo chat mignon est
assez terrible en parallèle de sa tous
les sites du gouvernement français ont
été traduits en chinois donc un un beau
pétrin pour tous a donc les pays tous
les pays commencent à accuser la france
commence à accuser de sa nuit les états
unis russie mais au final la taxe n'est
pas revendique donc des milliers
d'internautes à travers le monde vont
commencer à s'associer à enquêter et
vont trouver l'origine de ces attaques
un appartement appartement dans lequel
débute les joueurs c'est l'animation qui
s'adresse à tous à partir de 10 ans et
on a 45 minutes tous raison mais il faut
programmer des robots réseau des énigmes
est-ce qu'il faut des compétences
particulières les enfants apprennent
déjà à coder mais pour les adultes
pas du tout c'est ouvert vraiment à tout
le monde il ya tout un homme vraiment
c'est une synesci et prom qui est
ludique et pédagogique est ouvert à tout
le monde pas besoin d'être tous et en
programmation pour réussir à s'en sortir
de cette escape room on a vu juste en
d'aidés publiques seniors réussir à s'en
sortir à vous l'avez dit ça dépasse le
simple jeu on sensibilise aux enjeux
sociétaux on aborde la culture numérique
on signale aussi aux plus jeunes faire
attention à ce qui se passe et j'imagine
exactement c'est cérons qui nous a
attirés dans cette danse et escape room
le but l'émission de l'atelier des
sciences est temps de transmettre les
les diffuser la culture scientifique et
technique
cette exposition n'a pas juste un
intérêt ludique elle a vraiment tout un
aspect pédagogique sur toutes les
thématiques ont assité justement c'est
france qui nous a attiré dans ce projet
car certains se sont déjà testé hier
comme ça c'est facile isolés ici où
certains l'ont dit et si on réussissait
ils ont au début c'est assez perturbant
comme escape room quand on nous on lance
dans le jeu on sait pas trop quoi faire
et donc il ya toujours ce petit temps de
d'appréhension mais ensuite
effectivement ils se sont lancés ils
s'en sont très bien sortis
alors c'est une animation a réservé elle
se fait pas dans la continuité de
l'exposition
il ya de la place il ya de la place mais
il faut réserver
c'est à la volée les prochains week-ends
déjà commencent à être bien remplie
merci antoine guignols alors on rationne
parce que ça dure jusqu'au 8 mars il ya
largement le tas le temps de le faire
donc pour participer il faut appeler la
commanderie des informations s'affichent
en bas deux micros merci à eux
cette fois c'est un rendez vous pour les
amoureux de la lecture puisque ce samedi
18 janvier c'est la quatrième édition de
la nuit de la lecture bien sûr saint
quentin en yvelines y participent et
avant de découvrir quelques rendez vous
sur l'agglomération et dans le
département plus largement un lot de
nathalie niveau elle est chargée des
actions culturelles de la médiathèque du
canal
c'est un moment de découverte du livre
là aussi effectivement il s'agissait de
mettre en avant le monde de partage de
découverte
la sociabilité aussi à l'intérieur des
équipements culturels c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas que des livres il ya tout ce
qui est le plaisir des mots et donc
effectivement nous allons avoir des
écrivains qui vont venir faire des
lectures on regarde maintenant quelques
rendez vous pour cette nuit la lecture
dans les yvelines sur saint quentin en
yvelines d'abord la médiathèque 17 mar à
elancourt vous attend dès 10h30 pour des
spectacles des jeux des contes ou encore
des lectures des lectures aussi à la
librairie le pavé dans la mare à l'est
aussi à elancourt une autre librairies
participantes c'est le pavé du canal
elle vous propose une rencontre partagée
entre la librairie et la chorale les
falbalas est tout proche c'est à
versailles la bibliothèque centrale vous
attend pour notamment des lectures
théâtralisées bien sûr la nuit la ligue
sur ce sont de nombreux autres rendez
vous des médiathèques et bibliothèques
organise elle aussi des animations
rendez vous sur le site du ministère de
la culture il s'affiche en bas de
l'écran un petit mot de cinéma à présent
cette semaine nous partons dans les
salles du ciné 7 à elancourt l'ubo quand
nous en mai notamment en 1917 au lait
coûte alors dans les salles cette
semaine au ciné cette plusieurs
propositions dont une à noter à partir
du 15 janvier le film événement de sam
mendes 1917 qui traite de la première
guerre mondiale donc film à voir dans
les halles à partir du 15 janvier
[Musique]
ici euros
et aussi le festival télérama dix films
à l'affiché
je vais simplement citer les titres le
très réussi film de tarantino à tous les
fils sont en version originale je
précise once upon a time in hollywood le
film de la dgi qui est formidable qui
est sélectionné pour les oscars les
misérables le très beau film de céline
sciamma portrait de la jeune fille en
feu douleur et gloire le dernier
almodovar martin eden de pietro marcello
qu'on n'a jamais passé au ciné 7 ainsi
que une grande fille de contenir bas la
golf et s'y mêlent de guillaume
giovanetti une programmation pour les
enfants la fameuse invention des ours en
sicile et deux avant-premières la bonne
épouse et la fille aux bracelets ce
week-end aussi les sept
[Musique]
vous ne vous en doutez peut-être pas
mais la pièce d'eau des suisses à
versailles abrite de nombreuses espèces
d'oiseaux en cette période hivernale
l'association nature et vous vous
propose de les découvrir lors d'une
initiation à l'ornithologie
le rendez vous c'est ce samedi 18
janvier à 14h30
et si vous êtes passionné d'histoire
pour l'aris production recherche 200
bénévoles pour un spectacle immersif
secret défonce met en scène les
présidents charles de gaulle et dwight
eisenhower au coeur de la guerre froide
une rencontre un sommet d'état au
château de rambouillet le spectacle est
prévu du 5 au 28 juin prochain ce
vendredi une dernière réunion
d'information est organisée et laissez
vous tenter
[Musique]
et c'est le moment de quitter les
yvelines pour un détour par paris cette
semaine nos confrères de via grand paris
nous emmène dans le monde du street art
l'atlas
artiste majeur présente ses oeuvres dans
une exposition au musée en herbe
regarder venez vous initier au street
art avec walk the line au musée en herbe
découvrez le travail de l'artiste
l'atlas dans cette exposition divisé en
quatre parties
le parcours est un voyage à travers le
temps et l'espace entre influences et
voyages qui ont façonné ses oeuvres de
l'archéologie à la calligraphie en
passant par l'art optique avec walk the
line l'atlas prouve que le graffiti est
un art à part entière du grandi dans les
années 80 à l'époque où il y avait des
vasarely derrière les panneaux
publicitaires
donc j'ai été complètement influencé par
l'art optique mais comme j'avais moins
une formation calligraphié qui mon idée
ici c'était de faire rencontrer l'art
optique et l'art calligraphique comme je
lé fais dans l'autre pièce avec le
nouveau réalisme en montrant des pièces
de vie des gays ou des pièces de keith
haring qui sont voilà des gens qui dans
l'histoire de notre mouvement ont ouvert
des ports et ont cassé des frontières
entre des mouvements
donc c'est dans cet esprit là aussi qu'
on a conçu et l'exposition des gossip de
montrer finalement comment les artistes
digère tout l'histoire de l'art pour
ressortir leur vision personnelle comme
à son habitude le musée en herbe propose
une visite ludique pour les plus jeunes
devenez l'atlas le temps de cette
exposition et tester les différents
ateliers proposés qui font écho au
parcours de l'artiste
l'objectif est d'initier les nouvelles
générations au street art voué à devenir
un genre majeur du 21ème siècle
en fait il a commencé maintenant il ya
cinquante ans à new york donc là on est
aux prémices de ce qui est en train de
se passer ce mouvement en train de
rentrer dans les musées et on a toute
une génération derrière qui connaît très
bien ce mouvement là et le fait de
intéresser des enfants à notre mouvement
fait que justement demain tous ces
enfants qui rentreront dans la société
feront avancer ce mouvement lui-même je
trouve que la france a un peu en retard
sur justement d'intégrer le mouvement du
graffiti du street art dans les musées
et une certaine réticence donc c'est
bien que musée en herbe mettre en
lumière des artistes que tout le monde
connaît mais dont les institutions
tourner le dos un peu quand même à ça
why the line de l'archéologie au
graffiti est à découvrir jusqu'au 22
mars 2020 c'est la fin du set site
loisirs vous pouvez revoir cette
émission en replay sur notre site
internet et applications mobiles
on se retrouve jeudi prochain sur tv 78
à 18h30 pour de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et